NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
UITのテオです
ユーザーインターフェースとテクノロジーを愛する開発者のためのポッドキャスト、UIT INSIDE、今回もやっていきたいと思います。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
今回はなんとVueコミュニティの本当に素敵なゲストが3人揃ったので、来月開催されるVueFes Japan 2025を盛り上げるエピソードをお届けします。
kazu_ponさん、アンソニーさん、Yogoさん、よろしくお願いします。
NOTE Speaker: kazu_pon
よろしくお願いします
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
では早速ですが今日は本当にスターメンバーが揃ったので、皆さんに自己紹介をお願いできますか？kazu_ponさんからお願いします。
NOTE Speaker: kazu_pon
kazu_ponと言います。Vue.js日本ユーザーグループの代表を主にやってまして、VueFes Japanの主催者でもあります。
あとオープンソースの活動でVue.jpというOSSライブラリのメンテや、最近はCLIライブラリ「軍師」なども作っています。
そんな感じでオープンソースコミュニティで活動しています。
NOTE Speaker: kazu_pon
よろしくお願いします
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
本当にVueのコミュニティだとkazu_ponさんのことを知らない人はいないと思いますね。
アンソニーさんも同じくすごく広く知られている方で、今日はなんと日本語で出演していただきます。自己紹介をよろしくお願いします。
NOTE Speaker: antfu7
はい、みなさんこんにちは。アンソニーと申します。急に日本語でちょっと緊張しています。
僕はVueとNuxtのコアチームメンバーです。メインはオープンソース活動で、前の会社はVercelです。
日本に引っ越してきて5ヶ月くらいで、日本語を勉強しています。頑張ります。どうぞよろしくお願いします。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
ものすごい日本語力ですね！正直、ちょっと羨ましいです。僕も10年前から日本語を勉強していますが、アンソニーさんの方が全然喋れるので、モチベーションになります。
最後のゲストはクリエイティブな方も来てくれています。毎週水曜日にアンソニーさんとYogoさんがボルダリングしているんですが、Yogoさんも今回のVueFes Japanで登壇されます。今日はそのクリエイティブなサイドもぜひ聞かせてください。ご紹介をお願いします。
NOTE Speaker: yogo_escentier
まさかボルダリングの紹介が先に来るとは思いませんでしたが、本当にただの趣味です（笑）。
私は特にフロントエンドでOSS活動をたくさんしているわけではないですが、東京芸大出身で作曲を学び、10年ほど前にプログラミングを始めました。
最初はオーケストラの作曲課題をアルゴリズムでクリエイティブにやってみたくてプログラミングを始め、Webの仕事は7年ほど前からです。
今はフロントエンドもバックエンドも触っていますが、Vue・React・Svelteも全部使っています。
今回の登壇内容は、音楽出身ということもありWebで音を使う知見を話そうと思っています。意外とWebエンジニアでも知らないことが多いので、その話をします。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Webで音楽を作る話はなかなか聞かないので、後でもう少し詳しく発表内容を教えてください。
でもその前に、そもそもVueFesって何ですか？2025年ということは前にもあったんですか？kazu_ponさん、お願いします。
NOTE Speaker: kazu_pon
VueFes Japanは、今年は2025年ですが、初回は2018年に開催しました。
VueFes Japanのコンセプトは「フェス」の名の通り、お祭りのようにVue.jsコミュニティが集まり楽しめることです。
2018年の初回は500名ほど参加し、2019年は台風で中止、コロナ禍を経て2021年にオンラインでリブート開催、そこからオフラインに戻し、去年は関係者含めて750名ほど参加しました。
年々規模が大きくなり、去年からは海外からの参加者も1割以上と、海外からも注目されるイベントになっています。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
僕も去年初めて参加しましたが、本当に祭りのような雰囲気で、みんなで盛り上げるイベントだと感じました。700名規模はウェブ界隈でも珍しいですね。
NOTE Speaker: kazu_pon
そうですね、他のJSやPHPなどのカンファレンスと比べても、かなり大規模なイベントになっています。運営も大変です。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
アンソニーさんとYogoさんは今回何回目の参加ですか？
NOTE Speaker: antfu7
僕は初めてです。
NOTE Speaker: yogo_escentier
僕は3回目かな。前の1回はオンラインで、3回か4回目です。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
今回はなんとお二人とも発表もされるということで、発表のアピールやティーザーをお願いします。
まずはアンソニーさんから。
NOTE Speaker: antfu7
僕の発表テーマは「Introduction to Vite DevTools」です。DevToolsは開発者ツールで、みんな知っていると思いますが、僕はViteのDevToolsを作っています。
Viteの中で何が起きているかをWebで見たり、プラグインの機能拡張もできるようにしていて、今後は他のフレームワークでも使えるように一般化していきたいです。
この新しいツールプロジェクトを紹介したいと思っています。ぜひ試してみてください！
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Vueコミュニティのすごいところは、Vueだけに留まらずWebエコシステムの基盤を作っていることですね。
SvelteコミュニティもVue発のエコシステムツールに頼ることが多く、ViteやDevToolsなどもそうです。
今回はVite DevToolsという新しい基盤をアンソニーさんが作って発表してくれるので必見です。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
ちなみに今回のVueFesは生配信などはありますか？
NOTE Speaker: kazu_pon
本当は生配信したいのですが、VueFes Japanのコンセプトは「祭り」なので、オフラインでリアルな場を楽しんでもらいたいという思いから、オンライン配信はしていません。
ただしカンファレンスは収録していて、後日YouTubeのVueFes Japanチャンネルでアーカイブ配信します。
東京に来れない方や遠方の方も後日視聴できます。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
続いて、Yogoさんの発表についてもお願いします。
NOTE Speaker: yogo_escentier
僕の発表は、標準のWeb Audio APIなどはMDNにも情報が多いですが、実際にアプリケーションで使うとなると情報が少なく、困る人が多いと思います。
例えばWebRTCで音声を流す時に独自処理を入れたい場合など、実践的な知見やWeb特有の制限、工夫を話します。
今回は初めてSlidevでスライドを作り、パブリックに公開する予定です。Slidevもアンソニーさんのツールで、Vueコミュニティへの感謝も込めて使っています。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
VueFesの魅力ポイントとして、今年もアート系のセッションに力を入れています。
去年は田中さん（IE3）の渋谷の桜丘ステージのモニュメント制作の話が好評で、今年は橋本バックさんを招待し、タイムテーブルでVueで作る実験映像のセッションがあります。
アートや技術の融合を体験できるのもVueFesの特徴です。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
また、セッションでは「The Future of FrontEnd」と題し、エヴァン・ユーさん（Vue作者）、ダン・アブラモフさん（Reactコア）、ドミニク・ジーさん（Vite/Svelte）という超豪華メンバーがパネルディスカッションします。
生成AIなどでフロントエンドのパラダイムが大きく動く中、各フレームワークの作者たちが未来を語る必見のセッションです。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
学生向けセッションもあり、アンソニーさん、kazu_ponさん、ウブゲイさん、ナオキハバさんが参加します。
OSSコントリビューションのきっかけや体験談が語られ、学生やOSS初心者にもヒントになる内容です。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
VueFes Japanは技術だけでなくアートやコミュニティの融合も特徴で、他では見られない発表や体験ができます。
また、リアクトやSvelteなど他フレームワーク界隈からの参加者・発表も多く、コミュニティの垣根を超えたイベントになりつつあります。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
VueFes Japan 2025は10月25日に東京・大手町プレイスホールで開催、一般チケットはまだ販売中です。
チケット購入者はウェブサイト上でネームカードを作成でき、当日もらえます。
公式サイト（viewfes.jp）もおしゃれなデザインなので、ぜひチェックしてください。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
今回はVueFes Japan 2025について話してきました。
LINEヤフーのフロントエンドコミュニティUITでは、こうしたフロントエンドに関する議論や意見交換を日々行っています。
過去エピソードには社内勉強会発のものも多く、今後も積極的に情報発信していきます。
NOTE Speaker: TheoSteiner
Podcastへのご意見・ご感想は #UIT_INSIDE でつぶやいていただけるとスタッフが確認します。
kazu_ponさん、アンソニーさん、Yogoさんありがとうございました。
NOTE Speaker: kazu_pon
ありがとうございました